I was just I was just in America and
everyone I met wanted to talk to me
about this version so they all want to
know you know Oh are they as good as the
American Queens probably what do you
think what one of the difference is what
are the strengths I don't see how the 10
if your business
[Applause]
one of the exhibit like in America the
the names of the drag queens you know
like mystique summers Madison Chi Chi
devayne the house of Davenport all that
here bag of chips do you kind of oh yes
oh yes I've named several queens I mean
not even before this televised I I can
feel a person's energy and I can I can
tell what their name should be you know
okay so on the couch would you give drag
names for our guests yeah okay all right
I'll start with Jack where were you born
I was born in Putney it's a very rough
part of London
and what's your favorite food anything
from weight trays okay okay your drag
name is Jackie blackballed I'll be the
judge of that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right yes now stakes are high the
stakes are high no no but that's it
really Dame Helen yeah if the Queen gave
you your dime the first record you
bought the first record you bought at 14
I am a poet Oracle we did I didn't have
a record player when I was 14 believe it
or not did you have a favorite band no I
wasn't really a bandy person Edith Piaf
was more that kind of thing okay so what
what's your astrological sign I'm a Leo
Leo yes okay yes all right
IV w uh-huh
I'm the voices in my head they're
talking yeah I got it got it
mm sir lady cheekbones
[Applause]
[Music]
you